okay Donald Trump last week announced
that he would be giving a another border
wall speech on Saturday at 3 p.m.
Eastern Time it ultimately got pushed
back an hour and it ended up happening
just after 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time from
the Oval Office on Saturday and it was
being previewed as this big compromise
that Donald Trump was going to offer
Trump was ready to deal and give this
fantastic set of of parameters to
Democrats to get government reopened of
course including funding for his border
wall remember the government shutdown
that is still going on is over the
border wall Donald Trump effectively
throwing a temper tantrum he already
gave one speech where he claimed that we
have an immigration crisis the solution
to which lies solely in a 5.7 billion
dollar partial border wall I'm not going
to play the speech for you you can find
it online easily and what I want to do
instead is just get into the analysis of
what was said but quite frankly another
reason not to play the speech is that it
was a repetition mostly of the things
that Donald Trump said in the first one
all of which the the ones that required
debunking we already debunked and
missing from the entire thing just like
last time was a discussion of the fact
that Trump promised that Mexico was
going to pay for the wall that's totally
utterly obviously off the table now and
it's not even being mentioned in these
discussions of the wall even though
Trump told us endless times Mexico is
going to pay for that wall Donald Trump
did a repeat
during the border wall speech number two
that quote drugs are coming over the
border and the wall is going to fix it
obviously that's a lie most of the drugs
coming from Mexico aren't crossing
anywhere where we would have a border
wall they're crossing through ports of
entry and of course most drugs in the
United States aren't coming over the
border at all Donald Trump repeated once
again the lie that undocumented
immigration holds wages down I've talked
about this before the corporation's who
are hiring undocumented immigrants are
to blame for any
impact on wages which by all accounts is
extraordinarily modest but the real
problem is that the corporations aren't
being punished for hiring undocumented
immigrants and the undocumented
immigrants are being scapegoated there
i've already widely talked about that i
won't spend a lot of time on it today
but Donald Trump's proposal and offered
to Democrats is what I want to focus in
on Donald Trump wants to begin with
number one 800 million dollars in
humanitarian aid number two 805 million
dollars in drug detection 2,750
additional border agents and law
enforcement new hires 75 judge teams for
immigration courts and of course 5.7
billion dollars for what he is now
calling a steel barrier along 230 miles
of border amazingly during this speech
Donald Trump actually said you know we
don't really need a border wall across
the entire border because there are some
natural barriers like bodies of water
which of course is exactly what we've
been saying for years at this point
Trump isn't actually realizing that he
doesn't want that full border wall he is
realizing that he's just not gonna get a
win on the entire border wall so now
he's pretending he never really wanted
the whole border wall anyway absolutely
unbelievable that the goal posts are
being moved in this way now what is
Donald Trump willing to offer Democrats
if they give him the 5.7 billion in
order to get government reopened Trump
is willing to give number-one an asylum
application process that would take
place in countries of origin okay this
is a big deal because there's this
discussion over
people are coming in these caravans to
the border and and they're coming over
illegally except no they're not they're
actually going to the border to request
asylum because there's no process for
doing that in their country of origin
Donald Trump is offering to create an
application process for asylum where
people can do it in their country of
origin and Donald Trump is offering
three
years of relief for daca recipients
during which they would know that they
don't risk deportation and a three year
extension on what's called TPS temporary
protected status for some undocumented
immigrants this is a ruse through and
through okay number one Donald Trump
framed this entire offer as it being a
good thing even from his perspective
that three years of relief and three
years of extension for TPS and for daca
recipients respectively would be part of
the deal if those are obviously good and
moral things
why did Trump take them away in the
first place and number two why is Trump
now offering them as what the other side
gets in other words if Donald Trump
agrees that everybody should be pleased
about the extension for daca recipients
and the extension to temporary protected
status why is it that those are the
things he's willing to give up if
they're good why isn't he saying that he
wants them as opposed to having taken
them away and now offering to give them
back only if we give him money for the
border wall that doesn't make any sense
but the real big issue here for me Pat
is that there's no path to citizenship
here for the daca recipients that's the
real issue because Republicans know that
they are not going to be able to weather
the political consequences of starting
to deport kids who were brought here by
their parents who were undocumented
immigrants that's not gonna fly for
Republicans and they know it so the idea
here of playing coy as if this is some
big concession even though it doesn't
actually include a path to citizenship
it is a complete and total ruse and I
support Democrats rejecting this offer
but the fact that Trump is even making
an offer that will make him look good in
the eyes of many I do think that we're
getting closer here to a compromise and
it may be something like three billion
dollars for the wall in exchange for
permanent protection for daca recipients
that may be something that I can get
behind I just I wonder if Trump is
willing to back off that 5.7 billion
dollar number for the wall I don't know
where he came up with that but he seems
to be pretty glued to it
yeah I'm quite frankly not married to no
money for the wall if what's offered is
actually really good because remember
the border wall is going to take much
longer than Donald Trump is going to be
in office to actually build and even
though 5.7 billion or 3 billion is Pat
is suggesting these are insane amounts
of money right the the the amount of
stuff that you could do with that amount
of money is truly stunning so I'm not
pretending like because it's the
government billions don't matter but if
3 billion were to be authorized in
exchange for permanent status for daca
recipients that permanent status would
be a really really big deal and even the
authorization of the 3 billion which
would in the end probably go using
Trump's math for about a hundred and
fifty miles of border fence or steel
barrier or whatever much of which would
clearly not end up being built because
of the slowness with which it would
actually take place I would be open to
that I am not ideologically opposed to a
single dollar for the wall if what's
being offered actually makes sense and
of course what Trump in his first offer
made available doesn't make any sense in
it's a total ruse and he's also making
totally misleading claims about what the
impact of it would be Donald Trump is
claiming that the border wall would cut
drugs and undocumented crossings by 50%
I mean that's impossible mathematically
remember that only a third of all
undocumented entries are even happening
via the border most of the drugs are
coming through ports of entry not
through spots and the border where a
border wall would be placed so the
claims as to how it would work are
completely wrong the offer is a
completely bogus ruse Democrats should
reject it and they should insist for the
time being on no money for the wall we
will negotiate on that once government
is open
Trump is increasingly in an untenable
position and that's actually a good
thing for Democrats and Nancy Pelosi's
approval numbers keep climbing and
climbing Donald Trump's keep dropping
and dropping from the low 40s now back
into the high 30s and they've been there
for a couple of weeks this is not such
an amazing deal from Democrat for
Democrats that they are in a peril
position by rejecting it in fact Nancy
Pelosi's approval rating has been doing
really well given how she's been
standing up to President Trump the wall
is something that low information people
can very easily get behind they can
pretend that it would be effective they
can pretend that it's the big alpha male
accomplishment for Donald Trump
but let's not allow him to do it unless
the offer is serious and if daka's
what's on the table there has to be some
kind of permanent status I you know I
don't want the wall I don't think it's
effective I don't think we would be
wasting money on it but I actually would
be open to some funding for the wall if
Democrats can get something serious on
Doc a permanent status and then lastly
by the way to go back to what Trump
wants which is 1.6 billion for
humanitarian aid and drug-drug
technology drove stopping drugs from
coming over nearly 3,000 new law
enforcement and border officials and 75
new judge teams for the party of small
government that's a pretty massive
expansion of government and I'm not
saying we don't need more judge teams we
actually do one of the reasons that
people are staying for such long periods
of time in these detention situations on
the border is that the immigration
courts are functioning really slowly
because they are not nearly as well
staffed as they should be so I'm in
favor of that but the idea that what
Trump wants is such a massive expansion
of government seems to have gone
completely unnoticed or deliberately
ignored by the so called small
government conservatives my question to
you do you think that Democrats should
accept this offer which supposedly Mitch
McConnell is going to bring up for a
vote in the Senate this week or do you
agree with me that as it stands right
now it should be rejected send me your
thoughts the show is on Instagram a
David Pakman show I'm on Instagram at
David Pakman follow us there pull up
coming about what you think Democrats
should do